and guys this is my personal advice to
you this whole approaching thing does
that [__] out the window
I'm gonna say it now
take it and throw it in the trash women
don't complain I ain't the men don't I
don't give up this is how to not
approach girls at the gym
because I hate when they're sweet ass
it's me so uncomfortable
feral like feral
there's mirrors everywhere so it's like
you can easily cat catch people
oh this is nothing
okay we're gonna move on to the 35 now I
want you to watch very carefully
[Applause]
it's the five as five pounds
excuse me you don't have to do that it's
okay no no it's okay I got it thank you
though
thank you
see what I mean all right here we go
let's go to the gym with girls
we got some girlfriends
oh God be careful I've gotta be [__]
careful
can't be too [__] not part of me
working out by myself looks like I'm a
forgotten dance
sorry that exercise just makes me laugh
I know it's the new thing because of
everybody trying to grow their glutes
and I see like everybody's gonna do that
exercises and you call me and then and
then and then you call me juvenile when
I go
there's something the worst thing is
that it's in fast forward so that's even
worse
it's just it's worse it's completely you
know what I mean please what did you
what did you think no nothing all right
was it was that it was generally it she
basically called the guy a creep and all
that stuff this guy made me extremely
uncomfortable at the gym this is why I
end up crying on stream I feel so
grossed out at times with the amount of
sexualization I experience hopefully
this spreads awareness for girls who
experience this type of treatment at the
gym stupid piece of [__] behind me she
Whispers in the microphone I hate this I
hate when there's weirdos gets to be so
uncomfortable feral feral feral that's
what she said in the video so here's the
extra context I found a squat rack in
the area in the corner of the gym she
wrote in a lengthy reply if you followed
me there after I did a reverse deadlifts
there was a plenty of ab machines to use
but he chose the one that was not doing
his workout half of the time the mirror
faced me and not the whole gym so he's
looking around there there was nothing
but a mirror in my direction I get
constantly harassed by men in public
spaces when I even showed inch of skin
so yes I get pissed when they glare for
disturbing the long periods of time I'm
not looking for views or clicks I just
posted this at spread awareness
I don't think it's bad to look at
someone once and you'd be like oh that's
a pretty girl but I personally put my
headphones in on I mind my business and
make sure to look unapproachable because
I only there to film gym Vlogs and work
on my progression in the gym I wouldn't
be there doing this for tension at all I
don't trust random strangers no person
should you don't know their intention I
can see how this makes me look like I
haven't inflated ego but I am an
attractive girl in the beauty standard
sense and I get extremely sexually
harassed online and it makes trusting
random strangers that I approach me
trigger my trauma which is why I respond
this way I'm extremely anti-social and
being hit on is never a compliment to me
I don't like to be approached I haven't
dated for a year because I despise being
sexualized it happens anyway and I get
frustrated it's normal for girls to feel
this way because it happens often can I
pause you two seconds go for it how do
we know if I don't approach you
I don't know your background
I couldn't understand that you have all
this background I don't understand I
sympathize with you but how how am I
going to know for you being approached
is never
a compliment
I can't know that
and in this society as a man I have to
approach so what the [__] am I like I
don't know it's not written on your
forehead my girl people who say this
kind of behavior is creepy it's so funny
to me
have you guys ever done any approaching
I've watched women approach people I
watched them do the clubs you want to
know what women do to approach a duty
Club if they see a guy they try to angle
themselves they see them right they'll
look at him through his peripherals
and then they'll try to angle themselves
a certain way they try to look available
and then if they move they try to get
into another place where the man can see
them and make eye contact so he can
approach right you start to strategize
and physically put yourself in places to
be able to approach no one goes oh she's
pretty I'm going right in there's always
a bit of attentiveness like I want to
just strip down
oh he glanced four times and guys 99 of
people when they approach anybody think
it over they have approach anxiety they
get worried about going up to the person
they get nervous about the prospect of
being rejected they think it over they
try to position this is a normal type of
behavior
and the reason why I'm saying that is we
look at this and we're like oh this is
an inherently creepy when in reality it
is how the vast majority of people get
approached think about somebody you've
liked before you've ever had a crush
how many times have you sat there and
glanced at your crush before ever saying
anything a few times how many times have
you thought about how you sit how your
posture is around the person you're
crushing on we do these kinds of little
things to Signal interest to the other
person hoping I've never done that
hoping that they reciprocate women will
sit there what do they'll do they'll
adjust their hair they'll smile at you
right is that creepy I'm just asking is
it creepy when women don't say a word
but they'll glance at you though and
they'll glance again right and ladies if
you're being honest you guys have all
done this with somebody you liked who
you may not have had that much contact
or someone you thought was cute very
briefly we all do a bit of signaling
with our body language inadvertently to
say we're interested or maybe we don't
even cognacy realize it but we're
displaying an interest
it becomes creepy when you're not
interested and I can understand you're
going to the gym you just want to work
out you're not interested but you also
have to understand that in this world
like preach said we do expect men to do
the approach to go out there and try
themselves we don't have a set of rules
where it says where it is acceptable and
isn't maybe the gym is off limits you
know maybe that's a spot where people
don't want to get approached ever hard
to say I also know a lot of people who
meet their Partners at the gym and they
start [__] from there so it's not a
clear defined rule like if you told me
the woman's bathroom I'd be like okay
stupid is not supposed to be in there
you know what I'm saying
if he runs hey he she sits down it's up
here oh y'all set to pee that's
different
okay I can understand and this is why I
said before in spaces where men and
women are calmly together for extended
periods of time it is very difficult to
have these spaces and expect no
fraternization I say this where it's
work where you have little at work okay
there's literal rules to not [__] your
co-workers they still do it they have
rules don't and everyone's like [__]
[__]
I'm getting my dick
and maybe it should
I just want people to appreciate that
they throw around this word creepy and I
want you to understand how this kind of
approach anxiety where we created a site
where men don't like the idea of a
project vast majority of dudes are
regular and cool are never gonna say
anything to a woman why because of
videos like this where they can get put
on blast by streamers some famous person
semi-famous person and then have
millions of people describe whether or
not they're really disgusting perverts
or something like that because they
glanced at somebody a few times that
they like
but let's be honest every single one of
you [__] have looked at
somebody that you've liked and glanced
at them including women never including
women never
never yeah well how what's your favorite
feature about the person I don't know I
like his eyes I like it the way he
smiles if you like his eyes and the way
he smiles you glance bruh
so we just
I'm not discounting that women feel
uncomfortable in these space because
they just want to go from nothing and
sometimes like if you're an attractive
female you get approached the whole time
okay
I'm not discounting that but let's also
be honest about the fact that most of
these Dynamics kind of work that way and
even though it's unfair to you and you
get tired of it him it might be the
first time you approached a girl all
month
it could be amen and he comes off the
first time and you bite his head off I
understand why you do but you have to
understand I don't even no that like and
it's not like he was inappropriate it's
not like he was rude yeah but I get that
you don't want to be in freestyle but
let's let's be what's up it was off I
think I I feel like he was off taking
the weight like that and just assuming
not asking anything like that was off
that was off you didn't ask you just
took the [__] and then put it try to put
it yeah that was a bit off I understand
but that was maybe uh I'm gonna say it
it was a bit
maybe a full pot like it was not as
uncomfortable but I wouldn't deem him
like the worst creep in the world yeah
that's what he did he said and you did
good you said yeah no I'm good I'm good
I'm good and he left he did the thing
where he left no interest like I cannot
know can I ask you
at the gym when you're doing certain
exercises don't people just come and
offer to spot you they offer it that's
all I'm saying he just took this [__]
and put on it that's what I understood I
didn't I didn't hear or see maybe it
went too fast that he was talking to her
he just took the weight and trying to
put it in this place yeah people offer
me they offer excuse me could you he
just he just went there and and I can
understand how abrasive that could be
you just assume and she eat that make I
could be in this day and age when women
don't want to feel like a dancing in
this chest and you do that I've been
yelled at for holding a door if you're
gonna go up to a weight that she's
already put there and then she's all
right and your intentions were probably
all right but you don't ask that's what
is it that that's what was his error
Absolutely I'll say that okay this is
what I disagree man's right there he
goes over he says he gradually can I put
it on right did he say that yes you
asked yeah did it he asked he said no
I'm good he puts it right back and he
walks away that's all you had to say
because of one thing I said is that I
said I didn't hear
so I think he didn't ask where you might
have thought that was very inappropriate
another person would be like yeah I
appreciate it thank you you know how
many folks at the gym start off
conversations that way very casually and
then they become like they create their
own little gym Community where they see
each other often not everyone's built
for that but what I'm trying to say is I
understand I got my own traumas and
there's certain things that people
infringe on on a regular basis that set
me off but I also have to do the work in
my head to realize they don't mean it
that way or I don't know that they mean
it that way or I don't know that they're
making a hugeful pie so I also got to
meet them halfway and be like no thank
you and then I leave it like that if
they keep watching after that then you
could infer that there's something wrong
you've established a boundary right you
said no and the person has continued
then I can understand and guys this is
my personal advice to you okay a lot of
people don't like this this whole
approaching thing throw that [__] out
the window
I'm gonna say it now
take it and throw it in the trash women
are complain I ain't the men don't I
don't give up that's how I suppose I
don't give a [__] I was supposed to be
y'all not doing that and cut that [__]
out I'll tell you what it is okay
because I've done it I don't know Pick
Up Artist thing I used to go to clubs
with sharpies and play games I got
videos and photos like I have proof I've
done it I've done the whole laundry list
I'm telling you cut that [__] out that
[__] is for the past that was for the
birds of yesterday today we got a lot of
pigeons so who
okay all right today's a different day I
have well how do I need to go I'm gonna
tell you really simple
build yourselves a life that women are
going to find endearing
and naturally things will flow from
there get your [__] in shape get your
money right I'm not talking about
Millions I'm talking about just have
your get your own place get a decent car
okay make sure you got some cool hobbies
and keep with the [__] pushing but this
whole thing of walking up to strangers
you don't know the whole thing of like
bro I see people lose their jobs for
Less
cut it out and I'm not saying this
because I don't want y'all to get none
I'm telling you it's just not worth it
it's not worth the time it's not worth
the annoyance and it's certainly not
worth everything else that comes up
because I don't think this guy's gonna
return to that gym don't do it
keep your [__] pushing
pause
because that sounded weird
this whole day and I don't care how much
women no we want I don't give a [__]
do you want it so bad go do it yourself
stupid nah just don't do it it's it's
really bad like we're not in a day and
age where we could do that we could
afford to do that like are you gonna are
you gonna afford to lose all the label
the creep be labeled not [__] that [__]
[__] that [__] I'm just gonna be in
these spaces and I'm just gonna be in
spaces you know I mean if I was you I'd
be that I'm gonna be in spaces you don't
do no approaching you just be and people
[__] don't want to talk to
they'll talk to or they won't you have
to be okay with going home alone
and I'm going to go to this step further
this whole thing like oh my God uh
people sexualize me Liz I'm tired of
these women going up to the gym in booty
shorts and a [__] bra and saying I'm
being sexualized no you'd be doing that
you're doing that you're showing off the
most amount of skin and clothes that
show your curves off in the highest
amount of weights and then complaining
because people are ugly or glancing at
you
girl
stop
just stop I mean I'm not saying that
dudes don't sexualize women who don't
we're just that way because sometimes
they even do but don't act like you
don't contribute to that either don't
act like that is it because I know I
know women who do make a lot of the
efforts to do a lot of the other stuff
and it does reduce a lot of the contact
they have so there's this whole idea of
like oh my God men are these like sexual
beasts and blah blah blah she was
wearing uh she was wearing things to to
train she was nothing she's not wearing
nothing that was sexual
for some people that over sexualize
people Ingrid when fall comes in and we
talk about gray sweatpants and we talk
about dick prince
no you should no what do you say yeah no
and it's not just ladies there's dudes
that go up in the smallest tank top
showing their nipples and everything
making sure you know yeah they wearing
sweatpants are like [__] hug their
cheeks pause
okay people go to the gym and wear the
tightest outfits not because it's great
for your pump that's not why you do it
though you do it because you like the
way it looks and you know what it
signals and if you don't you [__]
lying to yourself they're peacocking
okay stop some of you women's gym
outfits look like your club outfits
it looked like you going to the beach
so let's cut this whole [__] out I'm so
sick of people oh my God the world is
sexual you in a thong stupid
well that was
but not her but people do that in
general I'm tired of people sexualizing
I can see your nipples through your
shirt and you're showing your bits
you're showing your bits people are
gonna look at your bits oh my God that's
okay this is
it's just the way people act is
everything is everyone else every day
all the time is everyone else yeah
you're with yourself all the time at
some point you got to recognize what you
contribute to these problems
there's a reason why Instagram models
all their thumbnails you can see they
ass
all the gym models who are not wanted to
be sexualized or blah blah they all got
a [__] thumbnail with a ass
showing funny and you women at the gym
are wearing the exact same clothes y'all
know what it is what are booty games
booty games came out of nowhere no
[__] trying to get booty for
one reason only it's because men like it
hey you know let's keep it a
stacking legging pants that was sold on
Tick Tock you know why they was popular
because you had that little culture on
top of the booty that just dribble come
on I mean I mean I mean that means your
booty look like it was hungry and just
ate your ate up your shorts stop that
exercise she was doing that's the new
fan on Instagram to get that Instagram
booty why y'all getting it let's keep it
in stack no it's for me
it's fine go look good do whatever you
want to do but I'm so sick of people
taking these decisions and acting like
it has no societal implication the only
reason you're doing that exercise is
because your favorite IG model uses it
because it gets a lot of eyes from Men
women didn't grow asses overnight
because they think that shit's amazing
no it's because of hip-hop and the
greater culture has made it popular
let's say what it is no they want to be
not comfortable when they sit down calm
down man we're over here yeah yeah 20
years ago when no [__] want to
ask what happened there was it women
showing their that's like yo these uh
there's parts of this that rub me the
wrong way with the way people go about
you know he's robbed the wrong way when
he's speaking French [__]